32 000 calories in one day is what he
guesstimates I did I have I I gotta tell
you whenever you're not with me you go
shopping and you do light drugs and
light drinking like drugs and electric
but you never do it with men heavy
eating it's the highest document about
any person had eaten was fifty thousand
calories in 24 hours by 750 pound man in
my defense I was very hungry
[__] first of all one of the shits that
wasn't how many I mean that was
continuous [__] you gotta have a lock
now I [__] came out of the water I [__]
continuously for about 45 minutes did
you flush or did you just let it pile
about it I would have went to multiple
bowls
you ate exactly 16 times what you were
supposed to eat in one day yes